bien après les européennes et avant les
régionales ce vent de rébellion au sein
du modem lors d'un conseil national ce
matin plusieurs cardin ont appelé à la
rénovation
françois bayrou semble avoir prêté une
oreille attentive à ses revendications
bénédicte de ré christelle jorion
derrière l'interdiction d'entrée le
premier conseil national un mois et demi
après la défaite aux européennes
les militants étaient réunis à huis clos
et il avait beaucoup de choses à dire
dont les sympathisants les proches du
conseil national ont dit ce qu'ils
avaient sur le coeur ce qui est tout à
fait extrêmement utile
quelques semaines après c'est bien
d'ailleurs c'est à dire c'est pas à vif
c'est bien et prêt à voir maintenant
comment on prépare la rentrée politique
sur les universités d'été du modem à la
grande-motte début septembre
et comment on fait pour résister
fortement la vie politique et française
bien sûr ils sont revenus sur les
chèques
françois bayrou jure en avoir tiré les
leçons désormais il faut tourner la page
on a le son principal que j'ai retiré de
ces éléments c'est que au fond les les
français souhaite que nous soyons au
dessus de la mêlée et pas dans la mêlée
et pour affronter l'avenir et les
prochaines échéances les militants ont
demandé un changement d'organisation du
parti christophe ginisty conseiller
national a écrit avec 300 adhérents une
lettre ouverte au leader du modem dans
laquelle il réclame l'élargissement du
bureau national et la nomination de
porte parole promis ce sera chose faite
dès la semaine prochaine
corinne lepage une des plus virulents
après les européennes et maintenant
satisfaites
alors oui je suis content de la manière
dont les choses se sont passées ce matin
oui et je ne regrette pas ce que j'ai
fait je ne regrette pas toute
l'effervescence qui a eu dans notre
mouvement qui lui a donné un vrai
dynamisme
pas un mot sur les possibles alliances
avec le ps ou europe écologie mais la
décision d'une stratégie nationale pour
les régionales de l'an prochain
cet automne il y aura même un grand
congrès pour élaborer le programme ce
matin le jeune modem a décidé de grandir